اعتمد مجلس الامن بالاجماع قرر ان يمدد
اليه ادخال المساعدات الانسانيه الى سوريا
لمده سته اشهر من معبر باب الهوى الحدودي
الى شمال غرب سوريا وكانت مصادر
الدبلوماسيه داخل المجلس استبعدت تستعمل
كل من روسيا والصين الفيتو ضد القرار
مشيره لان الفشل في تمريره كان ليتسبب في
تداعيات الانسانيه خطيره يدفع ثمنها
المدني
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا نناقشه في
مسارات ثلاث
ما هي ابعاد نجاح مجلس الامن الدولي في
اعتماد قرار تجديده اليه ادخال المساعدات
الامميه عبر الحدود الى شمال غرب سوريا
بالاجماع وما مدى تاثر قرار التصويت
بالحركه السياسيه والاقليمي والدولي وفي
اي اتجاه يمكن ان يقود التفاعل الذي ادى
الى اتخاذه الى اين تسيروا الازمه
الانسانيه في سوريا مستقبلا في ضوئي هذا
القرار وسط المخاوف من انت تتجدد العوائق
في طريقه مستقبلا وهو الذي يستمر مفعوله
فقط 16
ويعالج اوضاعا الانسانيه قاسيه ومعقده
لملايين السوري
[موسيقى]
تبدلت اذا المخاوف وتاكدت التوقعاته بشان
قرار تمديد العمل باليه ادخال المساعدات
الانسانيه الى سوريا عبر الحدود لمده سته
اشهر الاضافيه بالاجماع اعتمد مجلس
الامنيه القرار الذي يحث على تكثيف
المبادرات باتجاه اغاثه السوريين في
اوضاعهم الانسانيه القاسيه البرازيل
وسويسرا هما من قدمتا القرار الذي يسمح
بادخال المساعدات الانسانيه عبر معبر باب
الهوى على الحدود مع تركيا دون اذن من
النظام السوري قبل التصويت اشارت مصادر
الدبلوماسيه الغربيه الى مرونه ابدتها
روسيا في المفاوضات التي قادت الى صياغته
ومع ذلك يتعين اتخاذ القرار اخر بحلول
العاشر من يوليو تموز المقبل
[موسيقى]
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من واشنطن
بسام بربندي التونسيه السوري السابق ومن
موسكو الدكتور نيكولاي سيرجي الاستاذ في
معهد
العلاقات الدوليه الروسي وابدا بضيفي من
موسكو ونيكولا سيرجو يعني دون ملاحظات
كثيره
ودون استخدام الفيتو روسيا وافقت على هذا
القرار ما الذي تغير يعني كانت هنالك في
القرارات السابقه مداولات كثيره واعتراضات
كثيره وملاحظات كثيره الموقف الروسي يبدو
انه لان بحسب دبلوماسيين ما الذي جعله
متساهلا هذه المره
السيد هتروح ستيل
روسيا لا يزال لديها مخاوف له علاقه
بتشغيل باب الهوى وادخل المساعدات
الانسانيه
لا توفر ما يكفي من المساعدات الى المناطق
التي تسيطر عليها الحكومه ولكن من جهه
اخرى
بعلاقتها مع الغرب الولايات المتحده وايضا
تركيا اكثر مما هي عليه الان بسبب هذه
المسائل لا بل تفضل روسيا ان يبقى الوضع
على ما هو عليه لكن علي ان انوها بان
روسيا خير راضيه عن الوضع الحالي يمكننا
ان نرى
هناك مشكله ازمه ثانيه اخرى
يبدو ان الاسره الدوليه تتجاهلها انا
اتحدث هنا عن الوضع الانساني في المناطق
التي تسيطر عليها الحكومه حيث هناك نقص
حاد في الوقود والكهرباء والغذاء
روس لديها ملاحظات لكن الاجماع شيء نادر
في مجلس الامن الدولي هذا القرار هو
تقريبا نسخه طبق الاصل من القرار السابق
ويبدو ان يكون الاطراف ارادت ان توقي
الوضع على ما هو عليه قراءتك انت لذلك
وتفسيرك له
يا ان تقوم باي عرقه لهذا القرار اللي عدت
عوامل العامل الاول بان الدول الغربيه او
الدول المالحه الحقيقيه لتدفع الكثير من
الاموال هي اوجد اليه جديده لادخال
المساعدات الى سوريا الى المناطق خارج
المناطق سيطره النظام في حال روسيا عقدت
او عقدت مرور هذا القرار فبالتالي هذا
سيضع في اي قدره لروسيا للتحكم بملابس
السوري على الاقل من الناحيه الانسانيه
يعني تم تنسيقها بطريقه ان اذا روسيا عملت
فيديو على اليوم القرار ستستمر هذه
المساعدات خارج الامن وخارج الضغط الروسي
او الابتزاز الروسي هذه النقطه جدا مهمه
النقطه الثانيه اعتقد ان التواصل العلاقات
او تطور العلاقات ما بين روسيا وتركيا
بخصوص الازمه الاوكرانيه وانعكاسها على
التواصل بين الحكومه التركيه ونظام الاسد
سهل على روسيا اتخاذ مثل هذا القرار الشيء
الرابع الثالث
المناطق الخاطئه لسيطره النظام فيها قوتين
كبيرتين غنيتين ايران وروسيا فريق فالقول
بان هذه المناطق ليس فيها خدمات اعتقد يقع
اللوم على روسيا وايران كونهما من دول
الغنيه بالنفط والغاز فبالتالي عليهم ان
يساعد النظام هم لا يريدون ان يدفعوا اي
مال في هذا الموضوع بموضوع الانساني
ويريدون ان يعولوا على اموال المانحين
واموال الامم المتحده لدعم ما خربوه في
تلك المناطق فبالتالي اذا قامت روسيا همم
بتعطيل هذا القرار تبيعاتها على روسياسه
تكون كبيره جدا هم بتدشر الوقت حتى نكون
هناك مشاولات والرؤوس طلبوا اموال اكثر
لتمضي صرفها في مناطق النظام السوري في
موضوع الكهرباء هذه الموضوع تم طرح سته
اشهر والام تم اعاده ترحلات اخرى لاصلاح
البناء التحتيه بعض البنت التحتيه على الا
تشبه البنا التحتيه العميقه يعني تصليح
بمعنى ترميم وليس اعاده بناء حتى تكون
مستجبه مع العقبه الموجوده في سوريا او
على النظام فبالتالي حصل الرؤوس على شيء
مما يريدو ولكنهم لم يكونوا بالموقف القوي
الذي كانوا فيه قبل سته اشهر همم وذكر
ضيفنا بالموس وعود اليه الدكتور نيكلاي
سيرجيو تركي والولايات المتحده وقلت ان
لهما تاثيرا في هذا الموقف الروسي ما هو
التاثير التركي والامريكي في هذا القرار
الروسي بدعم هذا القرار في مجلس الامن
المنظر الى ارتباط ذلك باوكرانيا في روسيا
من امريكا
ومن هذا المنطلق فان الحفاظ على علاقات
طيبه مع تركيا
كذلك ليس ضروريا اقامه على علاقات او
بالاحرى
تخريب العلاقات المتحده وجعلها اسوء ما هي
عليه
ان تتلف اي مشاكل مع الامريكيين في سوريا
في الشرق الاوسط بسرعه عامه هذا نكته
وايران موجوده ثاني في الميدان على الارض
في المناطق التي تسيطر عليها الحكومه
سوريا ولكن ليس لديهما الاموال من اجل
اعاده الاعمار وحتى عمليات التعافي
الاوليه لان ااه الاضرار كبيره وجسيمه وهي
اصلا كانت قبل فتره طويله من وصول ودخول
همم روسيا الى سوريا وبالتالي مطلوب
مساعدات من كل اعضاء الاسره الدوليه هي
ليست مشكله محصوره بمساعدات من ايران او
روسيا هي ايضا تنسحب على دول اخرى من
المنطقه
سته اشهر فقط هل يمكن ان يتغير اي شيء في
خلال السته اشهر المقبله بحيث حينما يحل
موعد التمديد يحدث شيء مخالف لما رايناه
اليوم
يعني شوف من سته اشهر من اليوم لكن لم يكن
احد يتوقع ان يكون هناك لقاء بين النظام
السوري وتركيا اليوم سيكون هناك لقاء بينه
وزيرين خارجين بعد اسبوع ثم قد يكون هناك
لقاء بين على مستوى الرئاسه بعد شهر او
شهرين من الان يبدو الى الامور ستستمر
تمشي بهذا بهذا الاطار بهذا المنحه لن
اعتقد ان سيكون هناك حتى مشكله في القرار
بعد سته اشهر سيكون هناك اريحيه اكثر ولكن
هذا لن يغير ستبقى المساعدات التي تاتي
الى مناطق شمال سوريا ستبقى تاتي عن طريق
تركيا يعني الشعب السوري في مناطق خالص
سيطره النظامهم لا يثقون النظام لا يثقون
باليه توزيع ولا يتقون باليه همم المواد
التي يتم ادخالها يعني التجربه المريره
خلال عشر سنين الماضيه لن تسمح
للتواصل السياسي بتجاوز العائق النفسي
والتاريخ الذي جعل هذا كل ما اعتقد اذا
اردنا نتوقع ماذا سيرجي بعد سته اشهر
اعتقد سيتم تجديد هذا القرار سيكون هناك
همم اموال اكثر تدفع الى سوريا سيكون هناك
حاله من ال- من التعامل مع الموضوع
الانساني بجديه اكثر لا تنسى اجوره هناك
مليون سوري في الاردن وجودتك مليون سوري
في الاردن في لبنان هذه الدول اقتصاديا
وضعها جدا صعب حل المشكله اللاجئين في هذه
الدول هي موضوع اساسي الاستقرار هذه الدول
وهو قرار سياسي حصرا من دمشق عدد التواصل
التركي والاماراتي والايراني والروسي وهذه
الدول جميعها تقترب الى نقطه الحال لايجاد
ال ياسين معينه ثمنها هي اللاجئين او
الحبه التي يجب ان يتبعها الجميع همم جميع
السوريين من المعارضه ومن النظام ان
الجميع عليه ان يقدم تنازلات كبيره جدا
لعوده هؤلاء اللاجئين اعتقد ان هذا ما
يدور في همم
الخرج الافكار همم بكل الدول المعنيه بشان
السوري بشكل بشكل
هل هل يمكن القول ايضا ان هذا الموضوع هو
جزء من الحل الاقليمي جزء من ما تسعى اليه
روسيا من جمع الاتراك مع النظام السوري هل
هذا القرار او الموقف الروسي الذي اتخذ
اليوم جزء من ذلك من هذا المصعد
لانه في الوقت الحالي ليس هناك بارقه عمل
من ان الدول الغربيه سوف ترفع العقوبات
في الحياه واحنا نقاط الرئيسيه هي فتحها
القدره الوصول على الاقل الى دول المشاوره
المزارعون السوريون يجب ان يتمكنوا من
بيعي محصولها الى دول الخليج السعوديه
تركيا
حياه المطافي سيكون هناك عمليه تعفي اوليه
لانه حاليا لا يمكن اعاده اللاجئين البلاد
مدمره هناك مدن مثل حمص
متضرره ضررا كبيره حتى دمشق متضرره ليس
هناك تمويل اعاده بناء المنازل لاستقبال
اللاجئين دمشق الان مليئه بالاجئين وليس
هناك ملك من المساكن هناك حتى اذا المشكله
المشكله الاقليميه والا فعاجلان ام اجلا
سوف نشهد على ازمه جديده ومزيد من
اللاجئين يتدفقون الى الدول المجاوره
استاذ بسام بما انك وطيف ايضا ذكرت ما ان
ما حدث في مجلس الامن هو جزء من هذه
الترتيبات للتعامل مع مع قضيه اللاجئين
ضيفنا من دمشق من روسيا من موسكو يقول ان
دمشق ليس فيها متسع لعوده لاجئين وليس
لديها اموال لدعم يعني لا تنسى ان هناك
اناسا بالفعل يغادرون مناطق النظام الى
مناطق المعارضه لان بها مساعده
ما الذي سيحدث في ازمه اللاجئين هذا هذا
الحل الذي يبحث عنه الجميع ما تصورك لشكله
اخي العزيز الحدود السوريه الاردنيه
مفتوحه الحدود السوريه اللبنانيه مفتوحه
الحدود السوريه العراقيه مفتوحه الحدود
السوريه مع مصر الاجواء مفتوحه بمعنى بان
اللاجئ السوري في هذه الدول الاربعه
المجاوره لسوريا وده مصر وبعيده لكن في
قلبنا والا تستطيعون العوده الى سوريا في
اي وقت لا يوجد نظريه حاجز يمنعهم العوده
الذي يمنعه من العوده هو فعلا النظام نفسه
الخوف من النظام عدم الثقه بالنظام تصرفات
النظام احاديث النظام الى اليوم الخوف من
الملاحقات الامنيه هذه درجه اولى لعدم
وجود قضاء عدم وجود اي اي حمايه لهؤلاء
الاشخاص العوده هذه الموضوع السياسي هذا
الموضوع الاساسي في هذا الموضوع اللي ياتي
تحته هو الخدمات وياتي تحته اعاده الاعمار
ولكن لن حتى لو تم اعمار مدينه دمشق
اللاجئ الموجود
اعاده الاعمار
من من الان عن لديه استعدادات الاعمال
في المناطق النظام السوري
لا يوجد احد اعتقد بوجود عدم وجود حادث
سياسي لن يكون احد مستعد ان يطلع ان يضع
فعلا اموال حقيقيه لاعاده الاعمار لاعاده
الاعمار هي جزء من حل سياسي لهذا انا قلت
ان حل مشكله اللاجئين هو حل سياسي على
الجميع ان يقدم تنازلات كبيره فيها من
المعارضه ومن النظام الكبيره جدا لايجاد
هذا الحل لعوده اللاجئين عوده اللاجئين
بالتنازلات يعني فيه تغيير المنظومه
السياسيه في تغيير ذو القوانين في قبول
للاطراف جميعها للعيش مع بعض
جديده غير موجوده اليوم
100% من نظام لا يمكن العوده يعني اليوم
بدنا نتكلم عن اربع مليون تركيا
في لبنان نصف مليون و700,000 في مصر
700,000 او مليونين او سوري موجودين في
دول الخليج يعني كيف هذول بدهم يرجعوا
الان نرجع على السؤال من سيعمر شوف
السوريه
اي شخص ان يعمر ومن الحد الادنى فالموضوع
المصاري قد تكون موضوع البنى التحتيه
الضخمه تحتاجه مواكبرها صحيح ولكن اعاده
همم بناء او ترميم البيوت الصغيره المزارع
المعامل اعتقد ان المصاري ليست مشكله
كبيره بهذا الموضوع الموضوع سياسي همم
100% السياسيه ما يجري اليوم التحرك روسي
مع تركيا مع الولايات المتحده مع هذه
الدموع دول الخليج اعتقد هي لايجاد اليه
للحل السياسي بحيث انها يكون هناك تنازلات
من جميع الاطراف في حال فشلت هذه الاليه
سنرها خلال ثلاثه اربعه اشهر لانها لن
تاخذ وقت طويل حتى نرى اذا هذه ستصل او لا
اذا ما فشلت هذه الاله الانسانيه السياسيه
قبل سته اشهر بموضوع المساعدات وما يدخل
المساعدات ومن يراقب المساعدات يعني
يبتعدون عن جوهر القضيه الى موضوع تفاصيل
تقنيه لا تخدم الحقيقه همم
للامم المتحده تحدث عن هذه الخلافات التق
همم تتحدث عن بعض التفاصيل الخلاف مع
روسيا تحديدا بشان كيفيه ارسال للمساعدات
الانسانيه الى السوريين المحتاجين لها
لاسيما في الشمال السوري قال ابو تيرش ان
روسيا لا تستطيع ان تحل محل حجم او نطاق
عمليه الامم المتحده الضخمه عبر الحدود
همم وعود الى ضيفنا ايضا من واشنطن
الاستاذ بسام ذكرت ما يجب على النظام فعله
فماذا يجب على المعارضه تقديمه من تنازلات
فيما يتعلق بموضوع اللاجئين واعادته
يا سيدي يعني اليوم بالامر الواقع لا
اعتقد بان هناك يعني من يستطيع ان نسميه
ممثل السوريين هناك معارضه سياسيه تمم
انتقائها من بعض الدول وهي تمثل تيارات
هذه الدول
ولكن نرى نبض الحقيقي للشارع عندما كان
هناك مثلا اي موضوع للتواصل مع النظام مع
تركيا مثلا كان الجميع يرفض هذا الامر
فبالتالي لقبول السوريين مره اخرى للعوده
انسى الموضوع السوريين في تركيا في الاردن
او لبنان لا يوجد شيء يمنع العلاج الضغط
السياسي يمنعه لا يوجد فيه قياده السياسيه
تمنعه اعتقد بانها هي الضمانات التي يمكن
التوصل اليها بين الدول للسوريين نفسهم
للقول بانه اذا في حال عدتم الى بلادكم
هناك مشاكل الامنيه لان كنت اعتقالات
لاعتقد بان المعارضه هي في مكان تقديم اي
تناسلات التنازل الحقيقي الذي سيكون الشعب
السوري ان يكون به تقبل العيش مع بقايا
النظام الموجود
دكتور نيكولاي واستماعتها
خلاف في المستمر مع روسيا ذكرت في بدايه
الحلقه انه ذلك ملاحظات روسيه والروس
نفسهم ذكروا ذلك همم المسؤولون الروس ان
هنالك ملاحظات على هذه الاليه بمجملها لكن
تم التغاضي عنها هذه المره بسبب انهماك
روسيا بحربي اوكرانيا عدم كما انت ذكرت
الاسباب لكن ماذا عند الموعد القادم هل
هذه الاسباب ستظل موجوده للموعد القادم
همم وان تذكرت حرب اوكرانيا وذكرت عدم
اختلاق او ايجاد مشاكل مع الامريكان ومع
الاتراك في الشرق الاوسط
انا اعتقد ان التصويت التالي سوف
يشهدون نفس الموقف حيث ان روسيا سوف تدعم
تمديدا لوصول المساعدات الانسانيه ولكن
روسيا تحتفظ بتحفظاتها وما تقترحه هو
انشاء اليات مراقبه اكثر موثوقيه ومصداقيه
لتوصيل لتوزيعه المساعدات الانسانيه
الصحيه في تدهور تدهور عفوا هناك ايضا نقص
في الادويه ليس هناك ما يكفي من التجهيزات
والمعدات المستشفيات اذا لابد من اتخاذ
بعض الخطوات من قبل الامم المتحده صعدت ان
سيدنا يعيشون في مناطق تسيطر عليها
الحكومه السوريه
والمعارضه وغيرها افضل من تلك التي يشهدها
من يعيش فيه المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
الحكومه
داخليا يعني معاناه السوريين
ولا يخفى على احد من سبب هذه المعاناه
وحجم هذه المعاناه لكن اسمحلي يعود مره
اخيره الى ضيفنا من واشنطن الاستاذ بسام
مع اقرار تمديد هذه الاليه لمده سته اشهر
ما الذي سيغره ذلك في مقاسات اللاجئين
السوريين في الشمال تحديدا
هذه المساعدات نحن بنتكلم على اربع مليون
شخص محتاجين الى مساعدات 4 مليون هو بلد
يعني عدد سكان بلد يعني كامل جزء وثلث هذه
الاشخاص اللاجئين يعيشون في خيم
المساعدات هي الحد الادنى لابقائهم على
الحياه الثانيه هي ليست مساعدات رفاهيه هي
الحد الادنى من المساعدات لالقاء هؤلاء
السوريين على على قيد الحياه حكما فعليا
على قيد الحياه يعني عندما تاتي موجه برد
الجزيره دائما جدا جدا برد الناس تموت من
الثلج
لا لن يكن يعني هذا القرار هو عباره عن
استمرار اعطاء الحد الادنى من مقومات
الحياه لهؤلاء المساكين الموجودين على
المكان ولكن ليس هو نقل نوعيه لاي شيء ليس
هو تحسين لحياتهم للاسف هذا كل مرض مره
اخرى مرتبط بحال سياسي انه يعوده هؤلاء
الاشخاص الى قراهم الى بيوتهم همم لن يكون
لن يكون بحاجه الى هذه المساعده نشكركم
شكرا جزيلا الشعب السوري الشعب الشاطر لا
نحتاج هذه المساعده نشكرك وشكرا جزيلا من
واشنطن بسام السوري السابق هو من موسكو
الدكتور نيكولاي سيرجي الاستاذ في معهد
العلاقات الدوليه الروسيه
وصلنا لنهايه هذه الحلقه من برنامج مورا
الخبر في امان الله
[موسيقى]